[Music]
this video is gonna sting a little bit
because I'm explain to you ten reasons
why people don't become rich and some of
them pertains you yes you you're gonna
say I don't like this video cuz a part
of this is me so before I get right into
it any questions thoughts comment
comment below and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel click on the
sub button as well because we've got
many more videos like this that are
going to stink if you haven't watched in
me let me get right into point number
one why you are not going to become rich
ready
you don't like rich people if you don't
like rich people you're not gonna become
rich okay very simple point number two
you think rich people are special you
think people who are very wealthy became
very wealthy because they are just so
much more special than you are it's one
of the biggest misconceptions in the
world they became rich because at some
point they said I think I can do
something with my life I'm sick of it I
figured out certain talents of mine I
don't like this thing my life sucks
I want changes and they changed very
simple you can do that as well point
number three you don't spend enough time
Lord let me explain to you why I want
you to go on your YouTube channel and
forget about if you don't have a youtube
channel go on the search button above
and click on history and watch the last
20 videos you have watched on YouTube
and this is what I want you to do
categorize the videos on which ones of
them are educational and which ones are
entertainment if 50 percent or more of
the videos are entertainment you're not
really fully committed to wanting to
become wealthy you're more committed to
become entertained and it's not going to
happen go on YouTube and look the top
1000 videos keep going until you find
the first video that has to do with a
how to you know how many videos are
ahead hundreds if not thousands because
most of the world doesn't care about
wanting to fully found the secrets about
business and life and entrepreneurship
they want to be entertained this is why
Hollywood make so much money because
they know most of the world it's full
Aegis committed to an entertainment that
maybe you go look at your search by the
way you can go on your history also on
your Google and look what what's that
you visit and what you do with your time
that you have point number four people
easily make you feel guilty about all
the decisions that you make
everything you do your girlfriend says
something you feel guilty your boyfriend
says something you feel guilty your boss
says something you feel guilty your
teacher says something everything to you
is about making you feel guilty and you
are crippled by everybody making if
you're guilty this leads me in to point
number five here's what point number
five is you worry too much about what
people think about you way too much
you know what point number six is it's
kind of a contradiction of point number
five but I'll explain to you why it is
point number six you worry too little
about what the right people think about
you what are the right people the right
people are the people that are helping
you get to the next level the right
people are the customers that are buying
from you the right people are the people
that are trying to give you an education
about business entrepreneurship
growing you worry too little about these
guys you worry way too much about the
people that have no desire to help you
get to the next level
zero point number seven you listen to
every single thing your parents tell you
to do my parents raised me a lot of my
discipline comes from my father I love
my mom I love my dad I bleed bad David
and bolos him for the rest of my life
but my parents are not entrepreneurs and
they're not gonna be able to convince me
how to manage my money manage my
finances they've never owned a mutual um
they've never owned the stock they've
never been millionaires they've never
been rich what can they teach me about
becoming successful in my life by the
way for some of you that are so
connected to today like oh my gosh
that's insulting it is not insulting it
is not insulting my kids let me explain
if my kid wants to be a professional
baseball player okay if he takes advice
from me on baseball on how to swing the
ball when he goes to the next level
there is a problem there I didn't make
it to the major leagues he needs to
listen to his coach I can't be a fan and
tell him hey this is what a rod did and
this is what you know ken griffey had a
beautiful swing but I'm just a fan hit
that kid better listen to his baton
coach it wasn't a major league baseball
the same goes with business your parents
love you your mom and dad are great
believe me everyone's parents are mostly
great they did their best with you not
everybody has perfect parents but most
people are pretty good parents they're
not gonna teach you how to become
millionaires unless if they did if they
did take their counsel if they didn't
scratch their philosophies for business
go on from somebody that made a point
number eight here's point number eight
you are
a to loyal to every single family
tradition that you have politically let
me explain
financially work ethic diet what they
eat what they complain about what they
about what they talk about you're
so loyal to those traditions so loyal to
them and now talking traditions are
prayer I'm not talking traditions up you
know getting together and you know
having dinner and breaking bread and
talking I'm not talking those kinds of
traditions I'm talking about the
traditions that have not worked for your
family traditions of money when they say
honey life is not all about money hey
babe I hope you realize you're working a
little too hard what do you want me to
do mom do you want me to work 9:00 to
5:00
so I'm broke for the rest of my life is
that what you want me to do what
happened to you guys are you guys doing
what financially you really want me to
stress out about money the rest of my
life I'm sorry I don't want to subscribe
to that thinking that's the traditions
you don't have to fully commit to those
traditions unfortunately most people do
point number nine you're an expert at
making excuses literally everything that
happens in your life you got a great
excuse for everything I couldn't show up
it was raining I was sick I had a flu my
dog was sick my mom wasn't in a good
mood such-and-such happen you know this
isn't what happened my leg I was
cramping I had a hard workout you don't
understand my favorite team is playing
excuse galore for everything if you have
that money is just not attracted to
excuses just kind of how this thing
works and last but not least point
number ten and this one it's you know I
mean I don't know what other way to put
it's actually quite simple your attitude
sucks if your attitude sucks no one is
turned on by an attitude like that
they're just not if your attitude is
always complaining bitching about
everything that's happened in your life
people just don't want to be around it
think about it this way you ever see a
guy that dates a hot girl and he's not
that attractive how do you think he got
her it's not because he's physically
attractive it's because his personality
is attractive his attitude is attractive
she just wants to be around him she
feels good he makes her laugh
you know he's like if you would go in
places life is gonna be good we're gonna
have a good time it's the same exact way
how money is money's turned on by
incredible attitude very simple to have
a great attitude by the way right it's
not that difficult to do but money's
turn on my great
so now you got those ten signs that
you'll never be rich you know what the
good news is every one of those things
you can change like this every one of
them so whatever you wrote down here and
you're sitting there saying man I suck
I'm never gonna be wealthy
I'm never gonna be rich yeah you are not
gonna be rich but we have certain things
in life that were given to all of us and
one of the great things about life is
you have a choice you can change you can
make a decision right now while you're
watching this video I am changing like
I'm telling you no one's going to
recognize me after watching this video
not a single person in the world my
family my mom my dad my dad my sister my
girlfriend you want everybody after you
watch this video for them to say to
follow on it's gone into you you have a
lot of coffee today to go to Starbucks
what do you want bro is everything okay
you're gonna say yes everything's okay
because I'm trying to attract myself
some money baby so I'm trying to do
trying to seduce is it working what do
you think mom dad and I count a little
bit different good things are coming
around the corner for me like this you
can change and then all of sudden start
things starts happening for you truly it
starts happening for you but you got to
change now again question thoughts
comments comment below if you haven't
subscribed subscribe to the channel
thanks for watching everybody take care
buh-bye